[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
schönen guten abend ihnen allen das
wichtigste vom sport hat auch heute
wieder kristin otto im blick
heute jährt sich die tragische
flutkatastrophe im westen deutschlands
ein schwerpunkt in dieser sendung
ein jahr nach der flut gedenken an die
opfer und eine gemischte bilanz des
wiederaufbaus
waffen aus dem westen raketenwerfer und
haubitzen geben der ukraine hoffnung im
kampf gegen die russischen invasoren
sommerurlaub mit service problemen
hotels und gastronomie in deutschland
kämpfen mit den folgen des
personalmangels
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es den krieg es gibt große
energie sorgen die inflation aber für
alle betroffenen für die heute vor genau
einem jahr ein albtraum begann dürfte
eine andere krise nach wie vor im
vordergrund stehen
heute vor einem jahr verloren mehr als
180 menschen bei der flutkatastrophe in
teilen von rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen ihr leben viele mehr
ihr zuhause ihre existenz die a die erft
und viele neben flüsse schwollen durch
extreme regenfälle blitzartig an von 1
meter 50 nachmittags stieg der pegel der
in altena beispielsweise an auf kaum
vorstellbare zehn meter achtzig über die
trauer und das gedenken berichtet anselm
stern
es sind erinnerungen an tod zerstörung
verzweiflung an die flut die so vielen
so viel genommen hat erinnerungen von
den menschen die hier im aartal vor
einem jahr ums überleben kämpfen während
die wassermassen ihre heimat versüßt
woran erinnern wir uns
erinnern uns an das gefühl vor dem
nichts zu stehen
wir waren fassungslos sprachlos und lena
auch wenn die erschöpfung der letzten
monate noch in den knochen steckt wir
schauen nach vorn wir haben nur diesen
weg
innehalten im kurpark bad neuenahr
ahrweiler der kanzler dabei als stiller
teilnehmer hier trauern sie um die toten
der flugkatastrophe
gemeinsam zusammenstehen damals und auch
heute das grauen noch allgegenwärtig
genau wie die kritik an politik und
verwaltung weil der wiederaufbau quälend
lange dauert ich kann verstehen wenn
ihnen alles trotzdem manchmal nicht
schnell genug geht wenn sie einfach nur
wollen dass es vorangeht und ich
versichere ihnen wir arbeiten jeden tag
hart daran dass für alle der
wiederaufbau gut gelingt vor genau einem
jahr rasen bis dahin unvorstellbar große
wassermassen durch das aatal sie reißen
brücken strassen häuser existenzen mit
sich genau wie in nordrhein westfalen
viele verlieren alles viele verlieren
ihr leben gedenken an das grauen heute
auch in euskirchen und auch im namen so
viele unserer landsleute
versichere ich ihnen
sie sind nicht allein
nicht allein bei der schrecklichen
erinnerung an die verheerende todesflug
vor genau einem jahr
trotz aller verluste allen leids die
meisten von der flut betroffenen
menschen geben nicht auf aber so schnell
das wasser vieles vernichtete ganze orte
wie etwa altenburg einen teil der
gemeinde altena so langsam geht es beim
wiederaufbau voran auch wenn viele
freiwillig halfen und helfen es mangelt
an profis es mangelt an material
teilweise auch an geld anna duda und
ariane güte
patina amanatidis kann wieder essen
servieren ihre pizzeria in bad neuenahr
ahrweiler hat sie aus den trümmern
wieder aufgebaut mit ihrer familie und
freiwilligen helfern mit dem aufbau
konnte sie schneller anfangen weil sie
bereits vor der flut einen kredit
aufgenommen hatte um das restaurant zu
modernisieren ich bin einfach froh dass
ich wieder ein ganz großes stück von
meinem leben zurück habe ich kann wieder
arbeiten das heißt ich kann auch mal
endlich wieder selber geld verdienen ich
kann meine miete bezahlen und wieder zu
hause wohnen aber das ist dann auch so
jetzt ist die luft raus
bad neuenahr-ahrweiler vor einem jahr
die größte stadt im aartal das auf rund
40 kilometern länge von der flutwelle
verwüstet wurde rund 9000 gebäude werden
zerstört auch nordrhein westfalen wird
schwer getroffen es sind unvorstellbare
wassermengen die ganze ortschaften
zerstören in nordrhein westfalen werden
12,3 milliarden euro wiederaufbauhilfe
bereitgestellt davon sind rund 1,6
milliarden euro bewilligt in rheinland
pfalz sind es 15 milliarden euro
wiederaufbauhilfe
bisher sind rund 500 millionen euro
bewilligt
kristall bei bonn bei utah bartels geht
der wiederaufbau nur langsam voran das
zehrt an ihren kräften ihr haus hat die
flut stark beschädigt 300.000 euro
schaden die zimmer der drei kinder sind
unbewohnbar stimmt es eigentlich dass
die kinder noch nicht hier wieder wohnen
können dieses persönliche
und dass man eigentlich keine
katastrophe sobald irgendetwas passiert
dass man es nicht wegstecken kann man es
einfach durch
utah bartels wohnt seit einem jahr auf
einer baustelle dass der wiederaufbau so
lange dauert das hätte die
alleinerziehende mutter nicht gedacht 40
prozent der hilfssumme hat sie bereits
bekommen doch es liegt nicht nur am geld
dass es lange dauert es fehlen oft
gutachter und es mangelt an handwerkern
und baumaterial
christel haas ist für uns in bad
neuenahr christel ein jahr danach was
hat man aus der katastrophe gelernt
naja die menschen die im aartal wir
haben es ja gerade gehört haben
natürlich gelernt dass der wiederaufbau
nicht zu schnell vonstatten geht wie sie
das erhofft hat und das ziemlich viele
und viele fühlen sich auch allein
gelassen aber natürlich gibt es auch die
erkenntnis dass klimaschutz und
hochwasserschutz natürlich in den
wiederaufbau mit einfließen müssen das
ist auch in der gedenkveranstaltung
heute angeklungen da gibt es auch ganz
gute ansätze zum beispiel will man
brücken nicht mehr mit mitte pfeilen
bauen damit sich bei einer flut eben
kein unrat daran staudt und man möchte
eine neutrale eine nachhaltige
energieversorgung für das aartal
schaffen experten aber sagen das reicht
nicht es fehlten hochwasserschutz
konzepte und vor allem brauche die er
mehr platz und es dürften nicht so viele
häuser so nah am ufer gebaut werden und
genau da ist eben noch viel luft nach
oben und das kostet zeit und vielleicht
noch mehr geld also sind noch viele
dicke bretter zu bohren wenn das ahrtal
künftig eine modellregion werden will
dankeschön nach bad neuenahr christel
haas die hilfsbereitschaft war sehr groß
auch die aufrufe hier im zdf vom ersten
tag an
163 millionen euro sind bis jetzt
gespendet worden und es bleibt noch viel
zu tun und wenn sie unterstützen möchten
so ginge es über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser und alle
informationen auch zum nachlesen unter
spenden punkt zdf.de und auf der zdf
text seite
was geschah damals am 14 juli 2021 im
aartal als die flut kam
eindringliche bilder und die fakten zu
jenem tragischen tag gibt es aktuell in
der zdf- heute- app
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine
da sind durch russische raketen angriffe
auf wie nizza im zentrum des landes
mindestens 20 menschen getötet worden in
der großstadt wurden ein bürogebäude
sowie autos und wohnhäuser getroffen 90
menschen wurden verletzt so ukrainische
angaben präsident zielinski spricht von
einem weiteren terrorakt gegen
zivilisten
die ukraine ist fest entschlossen einen
größeren gegenangriff zu starten möglich
auch dank westlicher waffenlieferungen
wie zum beispiel mehrfach raketenwerfer
aus den usa oder panzerhaubitzen aus
deutschland die waffen ermöglichen es
aus großer entfernung russische
stellungen zu attackieren auf diese
weise sollen die camel truppen schon
empfindlich getroffen worden sein mehr
erfahren wer jetzt von antoine
kurschilgen ein amerikanischer heimers
raketenwerfer im einsatz in der ukraine
mit diesen modernen waffensystemen kann
die ukrainische armee jetzt russische
stellungen angreifen wie vorher außer
reichweite waren die heimat geschosse
fliegen bis zu 90 kilometer weit und
sind sehr präzise in lugansk explodiert
ein russisches munitionsdepot
also ich bin bei solchen
erfolgsmeldungen immer von natur aus
sehr vorsichtig weil ich sage ja wohl
scheint aber tatsächlich so zu sein dass
dieser heimers geräte ihrer großen
reichweite tatsächlich im schlaf mal
vorsichtig im donners bereich im
internet hinter der russischen front
eine relativ wichtige rolle spielen wo
genau die raketenwerfer operieren ist
streng geheim aus taktischen gründen
sie haben keine panzerung und können
schnell zerstört werden jeden tag werden
sie an einem anderen ort eingesetzt
damit sie kein leichtes ziel sind in der
ukrainischen bevölkerung lösen sie
hoffnung aus
als wir diese waffen noch nicht hatten
flogen hier ständig russische flugzeuge
jetzt ist das anders und das ist gut so
auch die deutsche panzerhaubitze 2000
kommt mittlerweile in der ukraine zum
einsatz ein 60 tonnen schweres
artillerie system zeichnet sich aus
einmal durch seine reichweite 50
kilometer plus zeichnet sich aus durch
die große präzision es zeichnet sich aus
durch die hohe geschwindigkeit
diese waffen stärken die ukrainische
armee sie allein werden nach
einschätzung von militärexperten jedoch
nicht die wende im krieg bringen
die eu-kommission rechnet durchaus damit
dass russland den gashahn zudrehen
könnten noch in diesem jahr und arbeitet
an einem notfallplan
ein entwurf sieht vor dass öffentliche
gebäude und büros ab herbst bis maximal
19 grad beheizt werden sollen auch
private haushalte werden aufgerufen
freiwillig weniger gas zu verbrauchen
voraussichtlich mitte nächster woche
soll der eu plan dann vorgestellt werden
und vor wenigen minuten diese nachricht
aus italien ministerpräsident mario
draghi wird noch heute abend
zurücktreten wir sprechen darüber mit
andreas postel in rom andreas was sind
denn die gründe für diesen schritt von
mario draghi
es gab heute eine abstimmung im senat
über ein hilfspaket was den menschen
hier in italien helfen sollte die
energiekrise und die gestiegenen preise
abzufedern die linke stelle bewegung die
fünf sterne bewegung hatte da einige
punkte die sie nicht mittragen wollten
mario draghi hat die abstimmung zu
diesem gesetz mit der vertrauensfrage
verbunden und die abgeordneten der fünf
sterne bewegung sind dieser abstimmung
ferngeblieben hat zwar die
vertrauensfrage de facto gewonnen und
die mehrzahl der stimmen erhalten
allerdings sind die fünf sterne
mitglieder nicht ihm gefolgt und
deswegen ist er heute zum
staatspräsidenten gegangen hat mit ihm
gesprochen und war jetzt am abend in der
kabinettssitzungen hat den ministern
mitgeteilt dass er zurücktreten wird er
wird jetzt die geschicke in die hände
des staatspräsidenten legen wird seinen
rücktritt heute abend noch erklären so
sagt er und dann wird man sehen ob in
italien eine neue regierung unter mario
draghi gebildet wird er selbst mit der
regierungsbildung erneut beauftragt wird
dann aber sicherlich ohne die fünf
sterne bewegung vielen dank für die ganz
frischen informationen live aus rom war
dass andreas postel
us-präsident beiden ist derzeit auf
nahost mission am zweiten tag seiner
reise ist er in israel und hat mit
regierungschef rapid über den umgang mit
iran gesprochen viele staaten befürchten
dass teheran an der entwicklung von
atomwaffen arbeitet das wollen israel
aber auch die usa mit aller macht
verhindern michael beverunger aus tel
aviv
auch am zweiten tag von joe bidens
besuch in israel steht ein thema im
vordergrund israels sicherheit und die
nukleare bedrohung durch iran erstmals
unterzeichnet der us präsident eine
gemeinsame erklärung mit israel in der
die usa sich verpflichten eine nukleare
bewaffnung irans zu verhindern mit allem
was in ihrer macht steht also auch mit
militärischer gewalt falls die
verhandlungen über ein atom abkommen
scheitern
wir meinen was wir sagen die verträge
liegen auf dem tisch und sie haben die
möglichkeit zu akzeptieren wenn nicht
lassen sie mich eines klarstellen
wir werden nicht ich wiederhole wir
werden iran nicht erlauben sich
atomwaffen zu beschaffen
israels premier sieht kaum noch
verhandlungsspielraum
diplomatie diplomatie wird sie nicht
stoppen der einzige weg iran aufzuhalten
ist die gewissheit wenn sie ihr
nuklearprogramm weiter entwickeln wird
die freie welt gewalt einsetzen
will
phosphor irans aufrüstung fürchten sich
viele arabische staaten genau so
iranische drohnen griffen auch schon die
arabischen emirate und saudi arabien an
das führt zu einer annäherung an israel
eine neue allianz einstmals alter fein
der entsteht da im nahen osten und im
zentrum dieser bisher noch informelle
nannte iran koalition steht ausgerechnet
der früher so verhasste staat der juden
nur ein extern gilt im neuen bündnis
noch saudi arabien nach einer
stippvisite im westjordanland reist
beiden morgen weiter nach jeddah seine
mission auch die saudis an bord holen
jetzt zur tarifrunde in deutschland
könnte ein neuer zweitägiger warnstreik
der hafenarbeiter die lieferprobleme der
wirtschaft weiter verschärfen wie hier
in hamburg haben tausende in den häfen
die arbeit niedergelegt die
verhandlungen momentan festgefahren die
gewerkschaft verdi fordert je nach
lohngruppe bis zu 14 prozent mehr geld
das angebot der arbeitgeber liegt etwa
bei der hälfte
ja wir sind in den ferien seite und
alles ist wieder offen die menschen
wollen wieder reisen aber ausgerechnet
jetzt fehlt das personal auf flughäfen
in hotels in restaurants wegen der
pandemie sind viele abgewandert und
komme nicht zurück elisabeth schmidt
über probleme dieser urlaubssaison und
sie berichtet jetzt von der nordseeinsel
langeoog
23 meter über dem meeresspiegel thront
das restaurant strandhalle auf langeoog
ein aushängeschild für die urlaubsinsel
weiter meerblick herrliche
sonnenuntergänge nur ohne matjesfilet
und lätzchen wollen denn es hat
geschlossen seit oktober es ist
dramatisch die insel ist voll viele
gäste rufen mich an und sagen wir gibt
wird eröffnet die strandhalle aber ich
habe einfach keine möglichkeiten wir
haben nicht ausreichend mitarbeiter
viele haben die insel verlassen arbeiten
mittlerweile in kliniken oder der
logistik branche und die korona sommer
werde verschärft die situation
zusätzlich
er musste für seinen kranken kollegen
einspringen und für hotelchef mag das
land ist die personalplanung zur zeit
ein einziges jonglieren es ist
heutzutage manchmal so dass wir
jemand eigentlich eine hauswirtschaft
ist dann mal für drei vier stunden auch
ins restaurant bieten dort mit zu
unterstützen und wir versuchen halt ganz
ganz stark auf auszubildende zu bauen
noch kommen die urlauber zehn prozent
weniger als im vorjahr die zahl der
tagesgäste geht noch deutlicher zurück
die steigenden preise gas strom
lebensmittel sind ein grund dafür und
vieles ist nicht mehr so wie früher wir
kommen seit vielen jahren nach langeoog
und haben deutlich den fachkräftemangel
jetzt bemerkt besonders nach krone es
sind viel mehr ruhetage einige
restaurants worüber gerne hin gestalten
wären die wert hinzu und da habe ich
einfach das gemacht um mitarbeiter an zu
locken bietet birgit colt bin da ihnen
sogar hotelzimmer als unterkunft an sie
hofft dass der arbeitsplatz mit
meerblick sobald wieder attraktiv wird
der süden europas ächzt unter hitze und
trockenheit in spanien frankreich
kroatien und in der türkei stehen
deshalb zahlreiche waldgebiete in
flammen schwer betroffen auch portugal
vor allem die mitte des landes
temperaturen von über 40 grad und starke
winde die ausbreitung der feier auch an
der algarve brennt es hier rücken die
flammen immer näher an wohngebiete heran
hunderte menschen mussten in sicherheit
gebracht werden
so und jetzt so königsetappe der tour de
france christin
und natürlich wahnsinnig anstrengend
sieger am ende des legendären
schlussanstieg nach alpe d'huez nach gut
165 km thomas pöck der brite triumphiert
als 31 der radprofi an diesem legendären
etappenziel einen deutschen gewinner gab
es übrigens dort noch nie
es war eine souveräne zieleinfahrt des
briten tom i spit kopf auf der
königsetappe der 119 tour de france der
cross weltmeister patrick er hat erst im
vergangenen sommer in tokio olympia gold
auf dem mountainbike gewonnen holt am
französischen nationalfeiertag den sieg
im alleingang zweiter wird der
südafrikaner louis mainz auf rang drei
landet der viermalige champion christou
das gelbe trikot verteidigte däne jonas
weniger hat erfolgreich am legendären
13,8 kilometer langen schlussanstieg
schritt poker nur zweimal an weniger
folgt jedes mal nahezu mühelos hd poker
nun im gesamtklassement auf rang zwei
nach
england oder deutschland die ja bereits
im viertelfinale der fußball
europameisterschaft der frauen stehen
sind auch die niederlande und schweden
auf kurs richtung ko runde
die schwedinnen besiegten in sheffield
die schweiz mit 2 1 und das oranje team
setzte sich inlay gegen portugal durch
titelverteidigerinnen tragen immer auch
die last große erwartungen mit sich doch
die niederländerin münchen zunächst
davon unbeeindruckt nach nur 16 minuten
stand es durch zwei kopfbälle von ego
roller und von der kraft schon zwei zu
null ein foulelfmeter von costa brachte
die portugiesinnen noch vor der pause
wieder in schlagdistanz
und tatsächlich konnte die nur einen
meter 61 große diana silva kurz nach der
pause unbedrängt zum 2 2 für portugal
einköpfen die entscheidung dann in der
62 minute durch den schönsten treffer
des spiels erzielt von daniel v mit vier
punkten aus zwei spielen hat die
niederlande nun beste chancen aufs
viertelfinale
und die französinnen können heute schon
15 allein sind
vom sport jetzt zur kunst einen bisher
unbekannten van gogh zu entdecken davon
träumen sie nicht nur bares für rares in
schottland ist das nämlich passiert und
zwar auf der rückseite dieses bildes des
meisters hinter einer papp schicht als
das museum es mit röntgenstrahlen
untersuchte erschien dieses
selbstporträt das bild muss vor 1888
entstanden sein denn das linke ohr ist
deutlich erkennbar das aber hatte er
sich in jenem jahr zum teil
abgeschnitten
heute nacht ein paar gewitter morgen
viele wolken mäßig warm und zu wenig
regen mehr gleich von katja von eva
bettina schausten begrüßt sie um 21 uhr
45 zum heute journal
der jahrestag der flutkatastrophe auch
dort im fokus das war es von uns wir
sagen danke und wünschen noch einen
entspannten abend
[Musik]
guten abend ein kleines tief überquerte
uns heute und es trennte mit seiner
kaltfront die 36 grad in süddeutschland
von 18 grad im norden dieses
temperaturgefälle bleibt uns auch in der
nacht erhalten denn mild wird die nacht
hier zwischen dem chiemgau und im
oberarm mit 17 bis 14 grad sonst wird es
bei 13 bis 8 grad kühler über
norddeutschland sie viele wolken hinweg
und es kann auch ein bisschen regnen bei
nordwest wird in niederbayern sind
einzelne gewitter nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen und im südwesten ist es
klar dort scheint morgen die sonne sonst
gibt es viele wolken und im nordwesten
deutschlands könnte es auch mal für
einen kleinen regenschauer erreichen bei
nordwestwind aber viel wird es nicht
sein die temperaturen steigen morgen an
den küsten auf 18 bis 19 grad sonst
liegen sie in norddeutschland bei 19 bis
22 im süden bei 21 bis 26 grad am
oberrhein steigen die werte bis 30 grad
am samstag kann es dann einige kurze
schauer oder kleine gewitter hier im
äußersten nordosten geben vor allen
dingen am vormittag der sonntag wird
dann trocken und dann wird es von tag zu
tag wärmer mit bis zu 35 grad am montag
gute nacht